on prime crime
the video that changed the country the
first time i saw the cell phone video i
was at a loss for words a controversial
defense
that's fine
like i said and the trial watched by all
i took probably 40 pages of notes as he
testified and i knew where
he had lied
[Music]
hi there everybody i'm jesse weber and
welcome to prime crime this is where we
do a deeper dive into the most
high-profile and memorable true crime
cases
this is a story that captivated the
entire nation and it all started with a
cell phone video
the video you're watching is from
february 23 2020
it shows a young man running in setilla
shores a neighborhood near brunswick
georgia
the first time i saw the cellphone video
i was at a loss for words
that man was 25 year old ahmad arbory
as you'll see arbory is running in the
direction of gregory mcmichael and his
son travis mcmichael
the video is from the cell phone of
their neighbor william roddy bryant what
happens next will change the lives of
all four men
within seconds a mod arbory is shot and
killed
i was searching for what else could
there be why would someone
do this
when police arrive on the scene they try
to figure out what happened by
interviewing all three men
i was in my
driveway
i look up this guy this guy
comes hauling ass down the street i'm
talking about in a dead run he's not
jogging
the guy he's in numerous occasions the
guy has broken into a house over here
nobody could ever ever catch him they've
had him on video according to the
mcmichaels they believed arbory was a
criminal a man they say had routinely
trespassed on the property of their
neighbor larry english in fact
surveillance footage from english's home
shows arbory previously entering onto
the premises
when you look at larry english's video
and you see a mod aubry walking in and
out of this property the question
becomes what are you looking at what are
you looking for why are you walking
around in this matter and so
consistently
when you've never had permission to do
so
we've had break-ins
my gun's stolen
okay that was outside so i'm running
running by the neighbors point and
everything so we saw who running by
out on top of the suspicious walking
around of ahmad armory you have a gun
missing from traffic michael's truck
across the street you have an item being
stolen from larry english's vote so it
starts to raise more questions than
answers
gregory mcmichael explains that even
though they didn't know arbory they had
a recent encounter with him
travis is leaving the neighborhood the
other night
as he's leaving the neighborhood he
looks over the in to the left and sees
this guy
walking across
a neighbor's yard
you know and he got he says the guy's
acting shady
at some point the lights hit him the guy
hauls ass into the house
an episode to which police responded
we don't see him back there unless he
jumped the fence
by the way
i think travis and his dad certainly
demonstrated that their goal in the
neighborhood was to try to protect
themselves and their neighbors from
crime
and there were other experiences where
they had done as they did
with mr armory where they had gone out
where they had taken firearms with them
where they had sought to understand why
the person was there or what they were
doing in the neighborhood or whether
they were connected to criminal activity
and they called the police
how did this all end though with a mod
arbory dead
he comes hauling ass down the street i
run in the house i said travis come on
let's go so
travis runs and gets his shotgun
because the other night
the guy stuck his hand in his pants
so we take off
the sleeve come around the corner he's
going down here we pull up beside him
hey stop stop we want to talk to you
and he just keeps on running travis he
backs up and says hey stop stop we want
to talk to you
so the guy i mean he's looking dead at
us you know i mean he's like me to you
and he turns and he runs travis gets out
with the damn shotgun and runs up there
the guy turns and comes at him
and they start wrestling and travis
shoes him around the damn chest he had
the guy was trying to take the shotgun
away from him
this father
said to his son let's go grab your gun
he's back let's go get him
to keep an eye on the number one suspect
he responded with nothing
no
explanation anything until the point
that he decided that his way out of this
detention was to attack travis
if he would have stopped
that's fine that's fine like i said just
is this just a simple case of citizens
stopping a suspected criminal as you'll
see
not at all
the black guy was tired of running he
seen meek around the corner right there
and he was like man i'm done
hi this is dan abrams with exciting news
for all of our law and crime followers
on youtube you can now get the live law
and crime network with youtube tv for
all of your daily live trial coverage
legal news expert analysis and original
true crime programs subscribe to
youtubetv today and then locate lawn
crime in the channel guide and for only
1.99 a month you can add the network to
your bundle
watch lawn crime every day with youtube
tv we put you in the jury box
[Music]
that's my son that shot him i was at the
back of the trail
i need to get this blood off my hands
back on february 23 2020 father and son
gregory and travis mcmichael are
speaking with georgia police they
explain they followed an
african-american man who was running in
their sattila shores neighborhood
believing he was a suspected criminal in
the area in fact that man later
identified as a mod arbory had been seen
on surveillance footage possibly
trespassing onto a property on previous
occasions and the mcmichaels had even
encountered him earlier that same month
we've had a string of burglaries
i was leaving the neighborhood and i
just caught a guy
running into a
house being built
i don't know if he's armed or not
the mcmichael's claimed that what
started with them following and merely
asking questions to arbory ended with
him running away and then attacking
travis with the younger mcmichael
opening fire in self-defense
however there's someone we haven't heard
from yet william roddy bryan the
mcmichael's neighbor who filmed this
shooting on his cell phone
so i hollered at him i said y'all got
him
and
he just kept running he was full even
though william bryan didn't have direct
communication with the mcmichaels
they're going to jump in to help just
because at least i think for brian he
perceives that to be the neighborly
thing to do
listen carefully though to brian's
description of
i pulled out of events driveway i was
going to try to flock him
but he was going all around it and i
made a few moves at him throwing the
damn windshield trying to chase his
joker you know he said we've been
chasing me i don't know
i
it soon becomes clear that these men
were actively chasing and blocking
arbory with their cars
in fact gregory mcmichael would tell a
detective quote he was trapped like a
rat
yet there's a serious problem with what
these three men believed about arbory
the evidence would show that not only
was arbory not armed with a weapon but
he wasn't committing a burglary robbery
or any violent crime that day and there
was no proof he had ever stolen anything
from anyone in that neighborhood it
seems that on the day in question arbory
may just have been jogging
to
have gone in the house and grabbed guns
having assumed the absolute worst in
their driveway decision that's where all
of this went wrong
you may think that these men were
immediately apprehended for what they
did
but rather they were all free to go
the mcmichaels weren't arrested until
over two months after the shooting
you have to look at the interaction
between gregory and mick michael and the
officers they know who gregory mcmichael
is and you can almost see him directing
the police officers as he's giving his
narrative as to what occurred and you
can see a sense of respect that these
officers give to gregory mcmichael in
taking that narrative
hey greg how are you i'm fantastic
[Applause]
gregory mcmichael was previously a
police officer himself he was also an
investigator in the office of former
district attorney jackie johnson
in fact this is the voicemail he left
her after the shooting
and i need some advice right away
combine that with the problems that
former d.a jackie johnson is now facing
and that she is being prosecuted for
showing favor towards the mcmichael
specifically gregory mcmichael that kind
of explains why there are no arrests off
the bat
i lost to my my family and i
and then we had to go out and actually
fight to get some attention
to get a rest
this arrest only occurred by the grace
and strength of what i believe to be
wanda cooper jones who stayed on this
story until it was made public and it
was the releasing of that video that we
all got to see what happened and the
narrative of gregory mcmichael and
travis michael and anyone else kind of
fell apart
in the end not only were gregory and
travis mcmichael arrested but three
weeks later so too was william bryan
mr bryant is the one who redirected a
mod not out of the subdivision but up
holmes drive so that he encountered the
mcmichaels and then became trapped and
pinned between the two pickup trucks
all three men would be charged with
multiple felonies including murder for
ahmad arbury's death
while many people across the country
were outraged over the killing of arbory
the legal question of whether these men
actually committed a crime wasn't so
easy to answer
when we return
[Music]
in may 2020 father and son gregory and
travis mcmichael as well as their
neighbor william roddy bryan are
arrested in connection with the shooting
death of a mod arbory
while the video of this encounter
captured on brian's cell phone became a
viral sensation across the country the
legal question became was this murder
according to the government these men
unlawfully hunted down arbory based on
an assumption he was a criminal although
they had no actual knowledge arbory had
done anything illegal that day yet the
mcmichaels had previously seen videos of
arbory possibly trespassing onto the
property of their neighbor larry english
also the mcmichaels had recently
encountered arbory entering onto that
property i've seen these videos so i
know what the guy looks like this guy
comes hauling ass down the street like i
said i mean like like something's after
him travis grabs his shotgun because we
don't have this guy's arm because the
other night the guy stuck his hand down
his pants uh it sled travis to think he
was armed
the mcmichaels and brian's defense teams
argued that although these men may have
been mistaken about arbory's actions
they did nothing wrong and were
protected under georgia's then citizens
arrest law which has since been repealed
if an individual commits a crime within
your presence or within your immediate
knowledge you are allowed to detain them
in the law's application of this case
the mcmichaels and brian are saying
that on a felony occurred within their
presence that they had seen a mont
arbore flee from larry english's home
and that this law allowed them to chase
after and effectuate a citizen's arrest
travis hall's ass up there tries to cut
him off gets in front of him the guy
turns and runs
call the police trust that they're going
to show up and do the right thing and we
know that in this case had officer rash
encountered a mod arbory he was just
going to put him on the phone with larry
english and let larry english decide
whether to issue a trespass warning
and that's what his standard operating
procedure was going to be which is of
course much different than what these
defendants chose to do
apart from the citizens arrest law the
mcmichaels claim they acted in
god damn it you self-defense
and then travis jumps out with it with
the shotgun and he runs up here and and
the guy
more or less attacks him
runs towards him and they get down a
fight over the damn shotgun and bam
the video showed
self-defense by travis because you could
very clearly see ahmad arbury
not turning to run away but turning
that dramatic left turn across the front
of the truck and traveling
all the way across the front of the
truck to meet travis at the other side
this was an attack
that a mod arbory was the primary
aggressor at that moment and that travis
had no choice he struck me a few times
okay
let him where where are you
the fundamental aspect of self-defense
is you cannot be the provocateur you
cannot be the person who is the initial
aggressor
while they make michaels want to ignore
that five minute chase of a mod arbory
the cutting off would be veering off the
bumping into a car the screaming out the
window
that's
initial aggression
there's something else to consider about
the video of the shooting
travesty michael had lifted up that
12-gauge pump action shotgun and
directed it at a mod arbory when he was
actually feet away from him and so that
shows a lack of immediacy a lack of
danger to his life and that goes
directly against any claim of
self-defense
william roddy bryan also claimed he was
protecting himself from
he was trying to get my truck
he tried to get in my door
but was arbory just protecting himself
from brian who allegedly tried to hit
arbory with his car
coming up the groundbreaking trial for
these three defendants and the testimony
you can't miss
and all he had done so far is run away
from you right
and i'll let him run away yes
i think all court shows are the same
we're talking about your father guilty
or not guilty guilty think again judge
caprio rules with common sense i was
having contractions i was rushing to the
hospital inspector quinn what does
justice demand jail
and compassion i'm going to take the
circumstances into consideration the
best court experience i've had clearly
judge he's been in a court before
get caught in providence
[Music]
hi i'm dan abrams in the exploding legal
and true crime genre law and crime is
the only network that has it all good
evening and welcome this is a
complicated case don't really jump to
conclusions welcome to prime crime
tonight another day of drama between
both sides from multiple live trials
daily to original and compelling
programming the lawn crime network is
everywhere and we invite you inside the
jury box this is law and crime
i pulled his arm out
and then i realized didn't have anything
in his hand
and saw that this
this ain't gonna last long
on november 5th 2021 brunswick georgia
took center stage as the trial began for
travis mcmichael his father gregory
mcmichael and their neighbor william
roddy bryan all three men were charged
with the murder of 25 year old ahmad
arbury the prosecution alleged that the
defendants assumed arbory was a criminal
and then proceeded to unlawfully chase
him with their cars and while blocking
his exit travis mcmichael gunned him
down a shooting captured on brian's cell
phone video
they shot and killed him
not because he was a threat to them
but because he wouldn't stop and talk to
them
the defendants argued they had
reasonable suspicion to pursue arbory
under georgia's then citizens arrest law
given that arbory had been seen
frequently entering onto a neighbor's
property without permission
ahmad arbury was not an innocent victim
he was a recurring
nighttime intruder
the mcmichaels also argued that travis
acted in self-defense when arbory
attacked him and allegedly tried to get
his gun away from him he is afraid that
he will beat him with his fists or
whatever weapon he might have and so he
raises the gun
as for william bryan who is in a
separate car from the mcmichaels he
tried to distance his actions from those
of his co-defendants mr bryant cannot be
a party to a crime by accident
roddy bryan didn't shoot mr arbor
roddy bryant certainly was not aware of
any intention on the part of travis
mcmichael to shoot mr arbory
covering this case in georgia was
interesting
seeing how people at restaurants or
people in cabs thought about this case
and how it affected this community
all eyes in brunswick and georgia in the
country were focused on this case
no day may have caused more of a stir
than when travis mcmichael took the
stand
and i said hey the police are on the way
as soon as i said the police he turned
and ran straight back down
i would have lost that grip on that
shotgun
that i've uh
that i would have been shot or i would
have been kind of been in serious
trouble at that point
and he was not relenting so i
shot again to stop him
i took
probably 40 pages of notes as he
testified and i knew where
he had lied i knew where he had
embellished i knew where he had
minimized
so it's fair to say you had incomplete
information about who was committing the
crimes in still shores yes
so you're telling this jury that a man
who has spent five minutes
running away from you you're now
thinking is somehow
going to want to continue to engage with
you
someone with a shotgun and your father a
man who's just said stop or i'll blow
your head off by trying to get in their
truck
that's
what it shows yes ma'am
you could have made sure that you and
your dad called the police from your
house at 2 30 satila drive before you
ever got in that pickup truck correct
i could have
you could have just
continued to drive
behind mr arbory and not even speak to
him or confront him at all isn't that
true i could have yes
after all the evidence and arguments
were presented and deliberating over 11
hours the jury returned their verdicts
malice murder
we the jury find the defendant travis
mcmichael guilty
felony murder we the jury find the
defendant greg mcmichael guilty
felony murder
we the jury find the defendant william r
brian guilty
thank god
we were just so relieved that
justice finally came for the family it
was a long hard fight
citizens arrest law in georgia did not
allow the mcmichaels and brian to do
what they did
i look at the video of
this incident
it's the frame of travis mcmichael
lifting the shotgun
to fire at a mod arbor and thinking
about a young man
that had been running at that point for
almost five minutes and it is truly
disturbing
judge wamsley sentenced both mcmichaels
and brian to life in prison but only
brian with the possibility of parole
the actions of brian showed almost
regret or pause or second thought as to
whether or not this was right and i
think that made it very easy for judge
wamsley to say you know what
consec
life sentences and will give a little
difference for william roddy bryan
i told you i love you
and someday
somehow
i would get you justice
son i love you
as much today
as i did today that you were born
he
is and was a human being a son
a brother
somebody who had potential in their life
to do almost anything he was an avid
runner
and they took his life at the age of 25.
his lifeblood just covering that street
in this attila shores neighborhood and
that they had no right to do it
at the time of this taping the
mcmichaels and brian face a second trial
this one in federal court on hate crimes
charges the allegation being that they
were racially motivated in their attack
on arbory you know it's really something
to think about where we are in this case
and especially how it all started which
makes you wonder if there wasn't a video
of the shooting do you think these men
would have been found guilty
would they have even been arrested
that's a question for everyone to
consider
that's all we have for you here on prime
crime leave us your comments on
instagram and twitter with the hashtag
prime crime as always thank you for
joining us and until next time be safe
[Music]
you